اهلا بكم قال وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي اتمار بن كفير ان اداره بايدن
تعرقل الجهد الحربي الاسرائيلي واضاف بنك
فير في تصريحات لصحيفه ول ستريت جورنال
الامريكيه ان رئيس جو بايدن ينشغل بتقديم
المساعدات الانسانيه والوقود لغزه وذلك
يذهب الى حماس بدل ان يقدم لاسرائيل الدعم
الكامل وقال بنفير ان رئيس الوزراء الا ل
بنيامين نتنياهو على مفترق طرق الان وان
عليه ان يختار الطريق الذي سيسلكه واضاف
انه ينبغي تشجيع سكان غزه على الهجره
ومنحهم حوافز ماليه من اجل القيام بذلك
كما اشار بن كفير الى امكانيه عقد مؤتمر
عالمي للمساعده في العثور على دول مستعده
لاستقبال اللاجئين
الفلسطينيين من جهته قال زعيم المعارضه
الاسرائيليه يائير لابيد ان تصريحات بن
كفير لصحيفه ول ستريت جورنال تمثل هجوما
مباشرا على مكانه اسرائيل الدوليه وتضر
بامن اسرائيل وتابع لابيد ان بنفير اثبت
انه لا يفهم شيئا في السياسه الخارجيه
وبان نتنياهو لا يملك السيطره على
المتطرفين في حكومته بدوره قال وزير
الوزير في مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي بني جانس
انه يتعين على نتنياهو ان يامر وزير الامن
القومي بالتوقف عن الاضرار الهائل الذي
يسببه الذي يسب
لعلاقات اسرائيل
الخارجيه معنا من رام الله مدير مكتب
الجزيره وليد العمري وليد الى اي درجه بن
كفير هو
يعبر يعني بشكل واضح وفج ربما عن شريحه
كبيره من الاسرائيليين ولكن في كل الاحوال
هناك نقد من معسكر اخر اطلعنا على هذه
الاجواء كفير وتوامه سموتريتش وهما من
الصهيونيه الدينيه وايضا من قوه يهوديه
تربيا على الكانيه العنصريه التي تدعو
لطرد العرب او قتلهم من هذه البلاد وعلى
عقيده كتاب المعروف
بوراه الملك او شريعه الملك
وباروخ جيفر بروخ الرجل وهي كتب قام
وضعها خامات عنصر ين تبيح لهم كل شيء بما
في ذلك التهجم على الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه التي تمد اسرائيل بالسلاح
والمال منذ بدايه هذه الحرب لذلك يعتقدون
في الحكومه الاسرائيليه وخارجها بان بنفير
و سموتريتش يتحكمان بنتنياهو وهو رهين
بايديهم لان همه الاول هو ان يبقى رئيسا
للوزراء وان
وتثبيت توليف فته اليمينيه العنصريه
المتطرفه من هنا ياتي راي الكثيرين في
اسرائيل بان هذان العنصران وحزبه ما هما
يلحقان الضرر والتصريحات التي ادلى بها بن
كبير لوول ستريت جورنال وهاجم فيها الرئيس
الامريكي بايدن بنظر كثيرين سواء من داخل
الحكومه او خارجها وهو ما عبر عنه ايضا
زعيم المعارضه لبيد وكذلك الوزير في مجلس
الحرب زعيم معسكر الدوله بني جانس تلحق
ضررا هائلا باسرائيل وبعلاقات الخارجيه
وتحديدا علاقاتها الاستراتيجيه مع
الولايات المتحده ومن هنا جاء طلبهما من
نتنياهو بان يامره الى الانضباط والا فانه
مواصلته في هذه الطريق من شانها ان تلحق
الاضرار البالغه باسرائيل ومصالحها
القطاعات الاسرائيليه واسعه في اسرائيل
التي ترى ذلك ب كفير وسموت مدعوان بالاساس
من مجموعات المستوطنين في الضفه الغربيه
وبعض المتطرفين داخل اسرائيل لكن هناك من
يرى بانهما لا يقويان على مثل هذه المواقف
لو لا يكن لديهما ضوءا اخضرا من رئيس
الوزراء نتنياهو فنتنياهو هو الاخر غير
راض عن تصريحات الرئيس الامريكي وواضح انه
يعارضها وقيل انه من بين الاتصالات الهاتف
الكثيره التي جرت بين نتنياهو وبايدن في
احداها قبل اكثر من شهر كان بايدن قد اغلق
خط الهاتف في وجه نتنياهو عندما وجد بانه
يقوم على مخالفه ومعارضه ما يطالبه به
بخصوص الحرب على غزه التصريحات التي ادلى
بها بن كفير واضح بانها تاتي امتدادا لهذه
المواقف ونتنياهو حاليا كان الامريكيون في
رساله تلميح وصلت الى اسرائيل قبل الزياره
السابقه لوزير الخارجيه بلينكن وهي
الزياره الخامسه السابقه وهذه الايام تبدا
زيارته السادسه الى اسرائيل منذ بدايه
الحرب كانت التلميحات قد وصلت الى اسرائيل
الى نتنياهو بان عليه ان يختار اما ان
يختار الانحياز التام الى بنفير و
سموتريتش او ان ينحاز من اجل استمرار
الدعم الامريكي لاسرائيل
ووفق التقديرات يبدو ان نتنياهو ما يهمه
وفق تقديرات الاسرائيليين هو الاستمرار
كرئيس للحكومه وان تثبيت توليفته اليمينيه
بالاساس وليس اي هم اخر لذلك يرى كثيرون
بانه منحاز الى بنفير وسموت ووزراء
متطرفين من الليكود من امثال ريجف وام
سالم وغيرهم من الوزراء المتطرفين الذين
لا يتحركون الا باذنه لذا المواقف او
العاصفه التي اثارتها تصريحات
بنفير في الاوساط الاسرائيليه واضح انه
سيكون لها صدى اضافي على ما قد ورد او صدر
حتى الان سواء من جانس او من لبيد وهو ما
من شانه ان ينعكس ايضا على تركيبه حكومه
الطوارئ التي يشارك فيها حزب معسكر الدوله
بقياده جانس وهناك من بدا يطالبه
بالانسحاب فورا من هذه الحكومه اذا بقي
بها بنفير وا اسم
على الرغم من الحرب وواضح حتى ان الشارع
الاسرائيلي الذي شهد الليله الماضيه سلسله
من المظاهرات
بخصوص ابرام صفقه تبادل للاسرى مع حركه
حماس كان قد رفع المشاركون فيه ايضا
شعارات تدين هذه الحكومه المتطرفه وتطالب
بعزل نتنياهو واسقاط حكومته واجراء
انتخابات وهذا يشير الى عدم الرضا من
طريقه الاداء التي تقوم بها هذه الحكومه
وتحديدا وزرائها المسيحيه المتطرفين جدا
امثال بن كفير وسموت الذين يعتقدون بان
بوسعهم ان يملوا ما يشا ان يملوا ما
يشاؤون على كل العالم بما فيه الولايات
المتحده التي تدعمهم وتدعم اسرائيل
بالكامل هذه الامور واضح بانه سيكون لها
مردودها وصداها خلال الساعات المقبله شكرا
جزيلا لك مديره مكتبنا من رام الله وليد
العمري